>> Laura: GOOD EVENING FROM
WASHINGTON.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS NOW
REPORTING THAT FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE HAS BEEN
FIRED.
YES, THE EMBATTLED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR, WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH HIM.
WE KNOW THAT HIS WIFE OBVIOUSLY
WAS RUNNING FOR STATE
REPRESENTATIVE, GOT HELP FROM
TERRY McCULLOUGH.
HIS PACT DONATED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS TO HER CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS NOT REVEALED AT THE TIME,
AND THAT RAISED A HUGE PROBLEM.
HE'S BEEN EMBATTLED FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS.
A LOT OF US THOUGHT HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN FIRED A LONG TIME AGO.
HIS PENSION WOULD HAVE KICKED IN
ON SUNDAY.
YET IF HE'S FIRED TODAY, LOOKS
LIKE THAT PENSION WILL NOT KICK
IN.
SAN FRANCISCO ATTORNEY HARMEED
DILLON, THE NATIONAL COMMIT
WOMAN FOR THE REASON NATIONAL
COMMITTEE FOR CALIFORNIA.
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
THIS REALLY SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED
A LONG TIME AGO.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WAIT UNTIL
TWO DAYS BEFORE HE WOULD RETIRE
AND HIS PENSION WOULD KICK IN.
NEVERTHELESS, THIS IS THE NEWS
TONIGHT.
YOUR REACTION.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
AWHILE BACK.
FBI DIRECTOR WRAY HAS TAKEN
STEPS TO REMOVE McCABE FROM ANY
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY.
THE OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DIDN'T WANT
TO ACT UNTIL HE HAD THE
RECOMMENDATION IN HAND AND MAKE
THE DECISION HIMSELF.
I'M GLAD THIS ACTION HAS BEEN
TAKEN.
CLEARLY MR. McCABE IS AT THE
HEART OF A NUMBER OF
CONTROVERSIES AND CONTINUING
THROUGH TODAY.
SO MAYBE THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF SOME RECKONING HAPPENING AT
THE FBI.
WITH THIS HEAD-ROLLING.
THERE'S OTHERS, LISA PAGE, PETER
STRZOK AND OTHERS --
>> Laura: AND WE HAVE THE PETER
STRZOK NEWS THAT WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO GET TO, HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE JUDGE WHO
HAS SINCE RECUSED HIMSELF.
LET'S GO TO ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
THIS JUST BROKE MINUTES AGO.
McCABE IS OUT.
YOUR REACTION.
>> I WANT TO SEE THE EVIDENCE.
IF THE EVIDENCE CONCLUDES THAT
HE WAS LESS THAN CANDIDATE AND
MISLED INVESTIGATORS, THEN THE
FIRING IS JUSTIFIED.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A HIGH
THRESHOLD TO RETIRE SOMEONE ON
THE EVE OF HIS RETIREMENT AND
TAKE A WAY A PENSION HE'S EARNED
OVER A LONG, LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> Laura: 20 YEARS.
>> GOOD SERVICE.
YEAH.
I WANT TO SEE THE EVIDENCE.
IF THE EVIDENCE JUSTIFIES IT,
FINE.
AS FAR AS STRZOK IS CONCERNED,
THAT'S AN OPEN AND SHOT CASE FOR
FIRING.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO STRZOK IN
A MINUTE.
HOLD THAT SEPARATELY.
A SEPARATE ISSUE INVOLVING THE
JUDGE IN THE CASE, WHICH AGAIN,
THIS COMES OUT TODAY AFTER
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER SARAH
CARTER BREAK THE STORY.
WE KEEP SAYING EVERY DAY, IT
CAN'T GET BUT KEEPS GETTING
WORSE.
JOINING US NOW, SARAH CARTER
THAT BROKE THE STORY ABOUT PETER
STRZOK'S FRIENDSHIP IN THE CASE.
SARAH, WE TALKED JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
YOU SAID KEEP YOUR EYE OUT FOR
THE McCABE FIRING.
IT HAPPENED.
TELL US WHAT LED TO THIS
HAPPENING TWO DAYS BEFORE HE
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN HIS PENSION.
IT SEEMS ODD THAT IT WOULD BE
HAPPENING THIS LATE.
WHY DID IT TAKE THIS LONG FOR
THE OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO COME TO THIS
DECISION?
>> THE OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, OPR, CAME TO THE
DECISION THAT THEY WANTED HIM
FIRED AFTER MICHAEL HOROWITZ
UNCOVERED A LOT OF INFORMATION
ON ANDREW McCABE --
>> Laura: THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
>> YES, AT THE DOJ.
THAT WAS REFERRED TO OPR.
A LOT OF EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES HERE.
THERE'S MORE THAN JUST
MISLEADING THE I.T. AND THE FBI
AND LEAKS, WHICH IS WHAT HAVE
BEEN REPORTED.
WE ONLY KNOW A LITTLE BIT.
>> Laura: GIVE US THE TWO OR
THREE THINGS THAT ARE THE MOST
EGREGIOUS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT CALLED INTO QUESTION HIS
PROFESSIONALISM IN HANDLING HIS
JOB.
>> CERTAINLY THE LEAKING TO THE
MEDIA, NUMBER 1.
ALSO THE FACT THAT HE LIED.
HE BASICALLY LIED TO THE FBI, TO
HIS OWN EMPLOYERS AND TO THE
I.G.
AND I THINK --
>> Laura: ABOUT?
>> ABOUT HIS RELATIONSHIP
ACTUALLY AND HIS FRIENDSHIPS
WITH STRZOK, ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH THE HILLARY
CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION AND
REMEMBER, HE GAVE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
APPARENTLY HE AUTHORIZED THAT.
WHEN THEY BROKE THAT STORY AND
HE WENT BACK AND THE I.G. SAID
HEY, WERE YOU RESPONSIBLE FOR
AUTHORIZING THESE LEAKS?
HE SAID NO.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO SOURCES THAT
I'VE SPOKEN WITH.
I THINK THIS GOES FAR BEYOND
THAT.
THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT POSSIBLE
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
>> Laura: WOW!
>> THAT COULD BE SERIOUS.
>> ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
>> Laura: CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME I'VE
HEARD THIS TODAY.
THE EARLIER TIME WAS 2:00 P.M.
FROM ONE OF MY SOURCES IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TODAY THAT
SAID YOU ALL KNOW JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT HAS GONE ON WITH
ANDREW McCABE.
20-YEAR VETERAN OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
VERY WELL-RESPECTED FOR YEARS.
APPARENTLY WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE OPR KNOWS AND WHAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL KNOWS.
WE'LL FIND OUT.
>> I'D HAVE TO AGREE WITH SARAH.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT HE
WOULD GET FIRED FOR THE LEAKING,
ALTHOUGH THAT IS VERY EGREGIOUS.
THE WALL STREET STORY THAT CAME
OUT, THE PRODUCT OF THE LEAKS,
WAS CLEARLY TO HAVE PAVED HIS
ROLE IN A DIFFERENT LIGHT AND A
LOT OF OTHER POLITICKING GOING
ON IN THAT STORY.
THAT WAS SHOCKING.
THIS SEEMS LIKE TURN AROUND IS
FAR PLAY.
WE'VE SEEN STORIES ABOUT HOW
GENERAL FLYNN HAS BEEN INDICTED
AND ASKED TO PLEAD GUILTY ON
CHARGES OF A LIE TO THE FBI.
YOU HAVE THE FBI, NUMBER 3 IN
COMMAND, TEMPORARILY NUMBER 1 IN
COMMAND LYING HIMSELF TO OTHER
FBI AGENTS.
SEEMS APPROPRIATELY TO HOLD THEM
TO THE SAME STANDARDS.
>> PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, A
FRIDAY NIGHT, TWO DAYS BEFORE A
MAN WHO HAS SERVED THE
GOVERNMENT FOR DECADES AND WAS
VERY WELL-RESPECTED BEFORE THE
HILLARY CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION I THINK TOOK PLACE
TO BE FIRED IN THIS WAY, I HAVE
TO -- I HAVE TO TAKE SARAH AND
HER REPORTING TO HEART HERE.
I DON'T THINK THEY WOULD RISK
FIRING HIM WERE IT NOT FOR SOME
FAIRLY SERIOUS INFORMATION THAT
HAS COME TO LIGHT AND WILL BE
REPORTED BY THE I.G.
>> THIS SOUNDS RIGHT TO ME.
THIS AFTERNOON I SAID THERE HAS
TO BE A HIGH BURN BEFORE YOU
FIRE SOMEBODY WHO HAS PERFORMED
IN A DISTINGUISHED WAY FOR 20
YEARS.
I HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
THE OPR, THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY DON'T GENERALLY GO AFTER
THEIR OWN.
THEY GENERALLY WHITE WASH THEIR
OWN.
WHEN THE OPR COMES TO THIS
CONCLUSION, YOU REALLY HAVE TO
GIVE IT SOME CREDIBILITY.
I STILL WANT TO SEE THE
EVIDENCE.
I BET YOU WE'LL SEE EVIDENCE
THAT IS FAR MORE COMPELLING THAN
WHAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT UP TILL
NOW.
WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT CRIMINAL
CHARGES, THAT SOUNDS VERY
SERIOUS.
IT'S DISTRESSING.
I HAD A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
McCABE BASED ON WHAT PEOPLE THAT
WORKED IN THE FBI HAVE TOLD ME
OVER THE YEARS.
BUT YOU CAN'T HAVE A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE SAME
STANDARD FOR DEMOCRAT, FOR
REPUBLICAN, FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE FBI AND FOR
CIVILIANS.
IF THAT STANDARD HAS BEEN MET
FOR CRIMINAL PROSECUTION AND
FIRE IT, SO BE IT.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYS THE
FBI EXPECTS EVERY EMPLOYEE TO
ADHERE TO THE HIGHEST STANDARDS
OF ENTECH
OF ENTEC
OF EN TC
OF EN TEC
OF EN TECH
OF ENTEEC
OF ENTECH
OF ENTEC
OF EN TC
OF EN TEC
OF EN TECH
OF ENTEEC
OF ENTECH
OF ENTECH -
OF ENTECH --
OF ENTECH -- IN
OF ENTECH -- INTE
OF ENTECH -- INTEGR
OF ENTECH -- INTEGRIT
OF ENTECH -- INTEGRITY.
OUR INTEGRITY IS OUR BRAND.
BASED ON THE REPORT OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, THE FINDINGS
OF THE FBI, OPR AND THE
RECOMMENDATION SENIOR CAREER
OFFICIAL, I HAVE TERMINATED THE
EMPLOYMENT OF ANDREW McCABE
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY.
HE SAYS THE FBI EXPECTS EVERY
EMPLOYEE TO ADHERE TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS OF HONESTY AND
INTEGRITY.
HE SAYS THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THE OPR
REPORTS CONCLUDED THAT McCABE
HAD MADE AN UNAUTHORIZED
DISCLOSURE TO THE NEWS MEDIA AND
LACKED CANDOR UNDER OATH ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
IN THE WAY IT'S WORDED, THIS
SEEMS LIKE AN OPEN AND SHUT
CASE.
YOU CANNOT MAKE EXCEPTIONS EVEN
FOR SOMEONE WITH A VERY
DISTINGUISHED CAREER AS A CIVIL
SERVANT.
PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS OR DO THINGS
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GET TO HIS